el anuncio hecho minutos atrás por el
portavoz del gobierno alí ravi de que
irán había comenzado hoy enriquecer
uranio al 20 por ciento ya había sido
anunciado días atrás por la delegación
iraní ante la organización de energía
atómica como respuesta a una ley
aprobada por el parlamento iraní días
después del asesinato de quien fuera el
padre del programa científico iraní muy
usted en fariza desde el cual irán
señala a israel que significa enriquecer
uranio al 20 por ciento pues si bien
estas cifras está lejos del 90 por
ciento que se necesita para crear una
bomba nuclear una una arma nuclear como
eeuu israel temen que irán planea a
pesar de que lo niega la realidad es que
si es mucho más cercano dar el brinco
del 20 por ciento al 90 por ciento como
lo han asegurado siempre los científicos
y por eso fue que cuando se firmó el
acuerdo nuclear en 2015 los firmantes
lograron bajar ese enriquecimiento al
3.67 por ciento y ya había roto este
acuerdo después de que
a dos unidos se retirará del acuerdo en
2018 y cuando irán empezó a retroceder
en sus compromisos se empezó a
enriquecer al 4.5 por ciento pero estaba
muy lejos de ese 20 por ciento que ha
comenzado hoy en la planta subterránea
de fondo lo que hará más difícil unas
posibles negociaciones entre irán y el
gobierno entrante del presidente
estadounidense joe biden